تم الإبلاغ عن المزيد من الضحايا المدنيين في
أعقاب الهجمات الصاروخية الروسية
بين عشية وضحاها، حيث فقد ثلاثة أشخاص على الأقل في
مدينة أوديسا الجنوبية
وقتل ثلاثة آخرين في
منطقة دونيسك الشرقية، وفي الوقت نفسه يطالب الجيش الأوكراني
بمزيد من المكاسب الإقليمية في
زاباريشا، وهذا هو المكان الذي نجد فيه
فريد بليك و  فريد، أعتقد أنك
تقضي بعض الوقت مع بعض
القوات على خط المواجهة، كيف
حالهم معنوياتهم، مرحبًا بك يا جوليا،
حسنًا، الأمر بالتأكيد
يسير بالنسبة للأوكرانيين، فهم يقولون
إنهم يحققون مكاسب إقليمية
في بعض الأماكن في  خط المواجهة على وجه
التحديد المنطقة التي كنا فيها حيث
قالوا إنهم تمكنوا من
استعادة قريتين هناك لكنهم
قالوا أيضًا إن المضي قدمًا
صعب للغاية وهم قادرون على المضي قدمًا لكن
الروس يقاومون
مقاومة هائلة وشديدة للغاية باستخدام  المدفعية
واستخدام الطائرات المقاتلة أيضًا، هذا
ما شهدناه
القوات الأوكرانية تطلق النار على
القوات الروسية التي تصمد في بلاغاتنيا في جنوب
أوكرانيا، هذا الفيديو الذي يقول اللواء
يظهر أن الروس يتخذون موقفًا نهائيًا
هنا، هذه هي المنطقة الأوكرانية التي
تدور فيها أعنف المعارك حاليًا  المكان ويمكنك أن ترى ما
حدث للكثير من المباني والمدن
والقرى المحيطة بهذه المنطقة ومن
المقرر أن يزداد القتال سوءًا،
نحن مع لواء جايجر 68 الذي
حقق مكاسب مهمة هنا
الجنود واثقون و  ممتن
لمعدات الإمداد الأمريكية
في كثير من الأحيان التي أنقذت حياتي،
ويقول إنها تنقذ حياتنا كل يوم من
قصف الشظايا والرصاص،
لكن بعض المركبات فقدت بالفعل ويواصل
الروس
إطلاق القصف المدفعي المستمر
وحتى الغارات الجوية.  قريب جدًا من
الراحة حيث اضطر طاقمنا إلى
الاختباء،
شكرًا لك،
لا يزال نائب قائد اللواء يقول إن
جنوده بدأوا للتو
هجومنا المضاد سيكون
ناجحًا بالتأكيد، ويقول إننا نؤمن بالنصر،
ونحن نتحرك للأمام نحو هدفنا،
نحن نتقدم  في هذا الجزء من
خط المواجهة، يعتقد الأوكرانيون أن
لديهم العتاد والقوة البشرية
والتصميم على التقدم بعيدًا داخل
الأراضي التي تسيطر عليها روسيا،
لذا يمكنك رؤية بعض
المعارك الصعبة التي تدور رحاها هناك على
تلك الجبهة الجنوبية في جنوب شرق
أوكرانيا.  وبالطبع كنا على
جزء صغير واحد فقط من تلك الجبهة،
يبلغ طوله عدة مئات من الأميال، وهناك
بالطبع مناطق يكون الوضع فيها
أكثر صعوبة بالنسبة للأوكرانيين. ففي
أواخر الأسبوع الماضي ادعى الروس أنهم
أسقطوا الكثير من الطائرات الغربية.
قاموا أيضًا بإصدار بعض
مقاطع الفيديو، لذا فإن الأمر صعب بالتأكيد
بالنسبة للأوكرانيين ولكن ما
لفت انتباهنا جوليا هو حقيقة أن الروح المعنوية
كانت عالية جدًا بين هؤلاء
الجنود الأوكرانيين خاصة بعد أن
تمكنوا من صنع تلك الصور الأولية  المكاسب
وهذه المكاسب مهمة للغاية، فهي تتوغل
عميقًا في الأراضي التي
يسيطر عليها الروس، لكنني أعتقد
أن الأوكرانيين أيضًا
يدركون جيدًا أن المضي قدمًا سيصبح أكثر
صعوبة من هنا فصاعدًا، فالروس
لديهم دفاعات قوية جدًا.  في
المناطق النائية، يستمر هذا الهجوم لجزء كبير جدًا
أو لمسافة طويلة جدًا،
ويعرف الأوكرانيون أن الروس لديهم
بعض الجنود الأقوياء هناك على
الأرض أيضًا، لذلك لا يتوقع أحد أن يكون
هذا الهجوم سريعًا
أن تكون قصيرة أو أن الأمر
سيكون سهلاً، في الواقع
يقول الأوكرانيون إنهم يفهمون ما إذا كانت الأمور
ستكون طويلة وستصبح الأمور أكثر
صعوبة مما هي عليه
بالفعل جوليا